thank you very much just thank you wild
crowd today where am i out-of-towners
anybody from out of town
hey have you tried our measles we've got
the best in the country oh I tell you
Disneyland's a mess
and it's not just the measles Donald
Duck has bird flu Pocahontas has
smallpox the little mermaid has crabs
it's terrible and the and the monorail
mono so now this has become a big hot
political issue this week Rand Paul you
saw this and Chris Christie they've all
said vaccination should be a choice not
a government mandate because when have
Republicans ever told people what they
can do with their own bodies it's just
not who they are uh but here's here's
something interesting from the
Republican side Republicans now are
stoners who care about the poor I don't
know if you heard
a couple of weeks ago they're all about
the poor and now it came out this week
too with them Jeb Bush and Ted Cruz
admitted this week that they smoked
marijuana in the past ladies and
gentlemen for the first time in my life
I feel like not using it kids don't be
like Jeb Bush he's no and I love this
Rand Paul called out Jeb Bush on his
hypocrisy because Jeb Bush you smoke pot
when you were a kid when you're in prep
school and then when he was the governor
of Florida oh you oppose medical
marijuana he just wanted people to go to
jail no treatment which is such
stupidity because Florida of course is
the perfect match for weed half the
population needs dinner at 4:20
but now what we don't know is about Jeb
and cocaine uh but we do know that he
did once hand his brother Florida on a
silver platter that that alright while
the other big controversies that broke
yesterday President Obama was speaking
at the prayer breakfast which I'd never
miss I don't know what I hate more
prayer or breakfast anyway and he was
talking about Christianity and he said
you know let's not get on our high horse
here as we judge the Middle East because
after all Christians have a checkered
past the Crusades the Inquisition we go
up a lot of people slavery was justified
with Christianity Republicans were
outraged and I could see there a point a
religious event is no place for facts uh
but yeah
what exactly do the Christians want us
to say about history the plants and the
animals were designed by God personally
at his drafting table like like the dad
from The Brady Bunch
but the Crusades just kind of happened
slavery not our fault Africa was
resisting arrest
and of course this is all very sensitive
this week because there's more barbarity
from Isis Isis is just topping itself
with the bra parity you saw would happen
with the Jordanian pilot they burned a
guy alive this time at least there was a
reaction of revulsion from the Muslim
world I wouldn't exactly say they were
up in arms about it after all no one was
drawn but but they were pissed because
you know beheadings sure we can
understand that mass executions
crucifixions okay bearing children alive
who doesn't after cleansing but this is
barbaric and medieval the Saudi said if
they got the guys who did this they
would chop their heads off right in the
town square so that they will not put up
with barbaric and medieval but and this
this other the latest Isis video they
found out look this is this they said it
is way longer than previous Isis videos
and it actually involves a storytelling
narrative at least four cameras at
advanced editing techniques what are
they getting in the movie industry boy
they're gonna be pissed when they find
out to get an Oscar nomination you have
to be white
but you know Jordan is notably pissed
about this and I'm glad they are they
struck back hearted Isis
you know bombing missions and so forth
and now Isis says one of the Jordanian
bombing missions killed an American
woman who was over there in their
capture and Jordan says no this is false
and Brian Williams says it can't be true
he carried that woman from a burning
building
rocket William O Brien Williams is not
having a good week I don't know if you
heard what happened but it seems for the
last 12 years Brian Williams has been
telling this war story where he's in a
helicopter during the Iraq war and it
gets hit by RPG fire and goes down in a
crash which is all true except for the
part about it happening to Brian
Williams he was in another helicopter
that was behind that helicopter that
that got hit but come on that happens to
all of us was when we get older come on
we misplaced our keys we have trouble
with people's names we can't remember if
the helicopter we were in crashed
and now people want Brian Williams to
resign but it could have a happy ending
because apparently what he said was such
a blatant departure from the truth today
he got an offer from Fox News